kisar dicks the PT free sweeps it around for Ben
Hut in behind here's car chips one in front and a
quick shot Demco the S Puck still loose and Brock
fer able to find it tip it out towards sou dises
off one timer Demco sliding to his right made a
stick save off Alex petrangelo the two time Cup
winner last year with Vegas 2019 with St Louis
here's a chance CS teners stopped by Den that
was eel now another chance Stone pass for eel
he missed it now he throws it in front D without
his stick and they score Third Time Lucky with the
Vegas golden knights Ivan barbashev on the backand
able to put it between the legs of Demco after
a wild scramble and it's one nothing never gets
settled defensively at the front of the net when
it's thrown towards the blue paint Deo loses his
stick everyone's try to look around to find where
the pucks going Nel puts it back out front kind of
why known his teammates are there and barbashev
sneaks at five hole goes off the stick and lands
on the back hand for barbashev to swat at look at
the frame five conu players but in the middle is
the goal scorer and this hits Demco in the inside
of the thigh and the right side but Finds Its way
through barashev gone to make it three to
one here's Pon down low JT Miller back up
to PS Miller again brings it in front po check
as he tried to get it on the forehead and this
is z Miller trying to do the pole drag and play
M down low to kzco back to Myers had to take it
on the back end now he dishes other side Connor
Garland back to Myers one timer stop rebound kzo
stopped as well Puck cleared hit Garland kmle
gets to the front he's looking for a pass or a
tip option then he just gets body position
and Bows away two chance Stone leaves from
patrano goes to the other side for Maro and he
sends the puck in deep two Vegas players got a
little confused down there but now Carlson to
eel Stone across Mara so stopped by Deno loose
PK in front Stone got In Too Deep to get a shot
of it as Vegas is able to find Marsha so we talk
toer chips the fck in Miller able to get to on
the left round but he's checked and back comes
Mar Stone through Center on the right side Stone
delays still has the puck pass was in the skates
of his intended target now com at the side of
the score Jack set up cross crease by barbish
and he roofed it to make it two nothing golden
knights eel has a goal in his 500th career game
part of the net odd man Rush looks like the
cuts are in a good spot but it's down across
and in before the cuts can get in front of the
passing Lanes nothing Demco can do about that
and Patterson through Center Miller down
the left drops to Hughes in the blue line
leaves for JT Miller top of the circle
ROP Locker Sav by Hill that was a good
one here's a chance for Garland off the draw
and he'll able to smother that one as well as
the Canucks got a good look right off the face
off picked up and brought in by Michael lario
he turns finds an open man Off the Bench porzak
with a shot stop by Demco Puck loose and still
loose at the side of the goal now able to grab it
get the whistle and there'll be a face off to his
left corac got the punk to the line can keep
it in here's Garland shooting missed the mat
Joshua gets the puck behind the goal cycles for
Garland brings it out sharp angle shot stopped
by Hill bler gets the puck back to the line to
Myers teas it up Freeman a one timer hooked it
wide Garland tried to Center for Joshua he's after
the PT came right in front and Luger attempting to
throw it across the crease couldn't get it through
to Garland here's Myers in the leaves behind the
goal for Conor Garland Joshua's in front Garland
feeds Joshua he shoots sto by Hill Dakota Joshua
got a good shot away and there was some net there
that he'll able to make the save and hang on for
the whistle this is Conor Garland and the Vegas
defense aren't going to come behind the goal line
literally the most polite exchange I've heard
in the NHL in probably 25 years yes Vegas to
the power play second time with a man Advantage
already leading two to nothing here's eel passes
down Carlson shoots he scores picked his spot
stick side on Thatcher Demco and a power play
goal for William Carlson makes it three nothing
kind of lethal with a couple of passes and then
Carlson having a little bit too much time to
pick his spot going to come down to the glove
side as Carlson will find his spot waits for
a moment and then beats that on the blocker
so eel picks up another point and Vegas who
was a little bit on the ropes there for the
last 3 four five minutes finds a power play
goal turns inside the Blue Line taken down by
Stevenson Puck turned over and here comes Vegas
H centered dmle a marvelous save sliding to his
right as he stopped Brad how into the middle of
conter trying to get it back to White Cloud but
JT Miller broke that up and here come the K
toer off the right wing go hold under shoots
stopped by Aiden Hill bra mcav dumps the fck
around barbashev angles it to the middle and
here comes eel already at three points eel shoots
D the same sliding back into the goal crease and
able to stop Jack eel Quin Hughes takes his pass
fires one down to Alias Patterson try to get it
across to Heron another block pass by Vegas really
don't let anything get across the middle now here
Stevenson ahead with a shot kicked out Bon got
a piece of it yeah Miller came on the ice and
was slashing across cross the Blue Line here's
Hughes towards the end of his ship moves in on
the left wing que Hugh HS B stopped and Hills got
the puck no rebound for JT Miller P assar back to
McNab fakes the shot now tries to rist one bler
steered that one to the far Corner here's carer
behind the net SPS his way towards the front
sent it across D the save he stopped a point
blank chance there for w now another chance and
I think Garland diving out need to save that one
Vegas able to control petrangelo wrist shot and
it's in cutting through the slot was Howen and
the puck either hit him or Demco went up in the
air and wound up in the net and it's 4 nothing
just 16 seconds into the third and as this is
sent across to petrangelo at the front of the
net bco is unsure of where it is as I think
it goes off him off Howen and in pet Angel's
just looking for bodies blocker shoulder
and Demco is unaware it's behind him and
maintains control allowing Vegas to complete a
change which he will now take party cter checked
itco tips the buck forward to Miller cut and Kenco
scores little give and go from the Blue Line
in and Andre Kenco has the Canucks on the board
and a nice finish PL it up the neutral zone
Miller Straight Ahead he's just trying to buy
a moment to get it over the Stick of Hutton does
so successfully kko takes off off the stick pass
the blocker upstairs and tucks get on the board
guso is Fourth of the season and as we hit the 8
Minute Mark of the third Vegas leading 4 to
one Sam locky nice move of the blue L takes
on the defense gets through and couldn't get the
backhander past Logan Thompson W gets it to White
Cloud R shot hit a leg in front rebound that was
kisar stopped by Thatcher Demco Canuck get back
on side egg back for the puck White Cloud takes
his pass delays and fires one ahead they could
be two-on one Maro with Carlson Maro off the
right shoulder of Thatcher Demco in front of
his reach lafer back in cuts to the middle th
shot sticks save by Thompson now with the blue
line ha making moves Puck comes outside the
line Vegas is offside here and that's going
to do it for this game as the golden knights
built up a three to nothing lead through two